[Music]
he's brent musburger who surprised a lot
of people yesterday announcing that at
the end of the month he will call it a
career in Brent
kind enough to join us when did you make
this decision Brent about 48 hours ago
really how are you mr. Patrick good good
you know I I might have thought I might
have thought about stepping into a new
role maybe 77 years ago you know you
never know I just you know I can't put a
date on something it at the time it
seemed like well sure do you like it
yeah what are you gonna go with you
you're gonna go in Atlanta and the under
well you know look at you know the only
action the Chaplin offshore its kind of
interested it hasn't been much you
should tell you guys and everybody there
hasn't been much action yet you know the
three is kind of a number that everybody
kind of sits on yeah and obviously that
inches to three and a half
Patriots by three and a half plus but
make that quite clear there will be
money will pound in on it Atlanta once
you know we refer to that as a hook you
know it's the only action that I can see
actually is the New England's been
better score more than 30 and a half
that's a that's gone to - 125 offshore
normally of course some of the folks who
don't pay attention to those kind of
numbers is normally - 110 - $100 but but
it's very quiet so far Dan last year
everybody at this time had jumped on the
Carolina Panthers bandwagon and Denver
money came pouring in late before the
Superbowl but this one it's quiet now
obviously there's an enormous enormous
respect for mr. Belichick in the in the
extra weeks I mean he's he's the best of
the coach and we all get that but
there's also people out there that say
beware there's a line of faculty they
they're capable of scoring a lot of
points you've been around them I mean
you know you and the guys have talked
about sort of like New England I mean it
was one of your featured attractions on
Sunday that's gonna be gonna be kind of
interesting so I guess you know Joe
Namath down here is Super Bowl it just
seems
and to uh to move on down the road and
you know because we've talked about this
hey you know what we got to do though we
winded Keith Oberman become this
progressive that they're really the
banner I mean I think I was looking for
a much brighter on Google website that
had enough Irish whiskey that I hit the
O button and I looked at over these
confident cars of the res I were a
weekend I mean come on I mean it's a
baseball guy I wanna know how many games
that cats are gonna play next year he's
out there calling but they should talk
to resign well what does this happen you
work with chief a lot charlie
we never spoke about politics in in all
the years we were together including the
five and a half years at the mothership
we did not discuss politics one time the
only political moment we had is he gave
me a book on Winston Churchill the last
lion and that was it
other than that we do not discuss
politics but yeah but you got free to
them on your hand Brent give Keith a
call I'm sure that you guys could you
know find out exactly what's going on
here yeah you know it's interesting that
you say that it said I'm fascinated to
hear that he was not politically
inclined with you know we all know that
he's a deep thinker especially about
baseball okay
and you should get him off that that
soapbox it is and get back to where we
enjoy him I'd love to listen to it talk
talk baseball and and things like and
that's fascinating to me that you never
got into a political conversation with
him about but go ahead I diverted your
attention there okay I was gonna ask how
important is gambling to you because
when you would call a game there would
be a veiled reference occasionally with
an over/under now now you're gonna go to
Vegas and you're gonna actually do this
for a living but when you were
broadcasting how important was did you
have money on every game that you
broadcast I know you know Dan that's
that's a very good question and I
stopped putting even a nickel on any
game goodbye
how about their soil way way back and
we're talking back in the seventies
last time I ever bet on a game I
broadcast Tony Bordeaux legendary Tony
Verner he was the first director I know
of working an army-navy game who brought
back a play after it had been run in
that game and thus the really the advent
of instant replay and Tony but anyway
Tony was in the truck we were going the
NBA game
it was Portland the Lakers and Tony and
I had a bet it was you know it was not
with a book here but it was man-to-man
and the youngsters name I'll never
forget was Johnny Newman and he was a
gunner who came down and I had the
Lakers at about three and a half it was
in Portland he came down a gun woman
from way outside is ridiculous okay ed
Portland got the rebound came back down
covered the number and I and I remember
jumping on Newman and when it was all
over and I had to buy Tony dinner that
night that's that's what we bet and I
went back to her I said you know that
was crazy I don't this is jumping on
that another kid it was a ridiculous
shot and I never bet a lot of people
think I did but but here's why but I
here's what I do think I do think it's
important to know what it is you know
our bully Al Michaels he's always aware
and if he's not George Hill stats guy
for both of us through the through the
decades he'll you'll handle a slip of
paper overnight even commercial with the
over-under might be and I do think that
people are interested in that I do think
it's a very very big part of the growth
of the National Football League now
listen I get it I think the integrity of
the game and the sport that's the most
important thing okay
and with what the pros are paid these
days in football basketball baseball I
don't worry too much about that because
I know how much it would take to try and
Bend somebody to try to fix a game at
the time college is you've got a people
of a closer eye on yeah because those
kids don't get any money so I don't
listen it's not the most important thing
I anybody listening to this it is to me
no it's not but it is a frame of
reference it is something to know
and something to keep in the back of
your mind I think when you go into a
game so you know we start out joking
about the Superbowl and it is something
worth watching and sometimes when the
game is all over and done as al
certainly had done through the years the
over/under number becomes becomes
important to the players who watch it I
just think it's a there are coaches who
will they will tell you they don't know
but they do know because they wanted a
boy you know one of these guys know that
I might not know the Vegas now to do
you're gonna have it you're gonna do a
family business here are you going to
give picks no you know that's one thing
I look let me let me make this perfectly
clear okay I'm gonna ask my two boys I
asked my wife probably do you like yeah
that's easy I have not the world's
greatest antic pepper and anybody have
my picks free I'd be glad to tell them
at any time I would do sell it and you
go broke that not my fix I had no better
day but I'm more of a recreational
better than and I'm not a professional
I'm not going in and say after that guys
whatsoever love to talk about it love to
talk about why the Patriots are favored
but I am more interested in when the
bookmakers moved to three and a half go
to four and you can go to seven you go
to ten you put your key numbers in that
world I'm interested in why is the money
show in some way or do you think this
team is so much better idea how do you
try to get people to come back the other
well I'm more interested in the in the
business of gambling on sports than I am
the actual handicapping because there
are many people listening to you and I
right now watching you the better
handicap person I am I'm not you know
I'm not a genius I'm gonna die I'm not
bringing any special tools to this
particular trade but I'm interested in
the business and the business includes
billions of dollars that are but every
year on the on the various sports some
of it on sure legally certainly in
Nevada and and a lot of it offshore and
with with mr. Trump in the presidency
I do believe that there is a chance that
that it will become legal in more States
than just in avada I do believe that the
business has it has a growth to it and
now with the Raiders apparently headed
for Las Vegas I need 24 votes from the
owners and National Hockey League is
already in there I'm sure the NBA is
thinking about it I doubt that Major
League Baseball would ever come to Las
Vegas but I but the but their growth
opportunities out there and they're
built around sports to me are intriguing
and fascinating can we take a break and
come back and talk a little bit about
the career can we can we look back on
the career open up the scrapbook just a
little bit yeah sure why not are you are
you okay with that I'm drinking a coffee
you know what was the over-under on
Irish whiskey last night right after
this in the Dan Patrick show it bummed
out a lot of people that you announced
your retirement you know that right yeah
that's that's been great you know
wandering around the country like I do
that you know there's so many sports
fans out there Danica they get the teams
and they love the boys you know we're
familiar with so many people because our
boys just come in and I made the
announcement your producer with one of
the first to call me and I knew that you
and Rich Eisen would be some people I
would talk to on the board today this
afternoon and it was interesting when I
mentioned you to somebody and it's a
charity I loved watching those guys on
Sunday night Tony
you could remember coach his last name
and uh it's interesting because you're
you're very familiar and we we switch
over on Sunday night I know I do when
I'm around and it's interesting to watch
how you produce the show at NBC and you
bring the you bring the light team's up
late because I just ended and you know
that audience
Sloane over there and then you'd go back
to the major story before you get out to
the field in the game and you're you're
very somebody and I got that I I
understand that and I love talking ball
I love being a guest in somebody's
living room
and I don't own the town though Brent I
mean you're going into college Townsend
and I said this yesterday that you can
go into Ames Iowa on a Tuesday night and
make it a big deal that that you're in
town and you made it you brought passion
and that's the first thing I think that
leaves you in this business is your
passion and it never left you
well yeah because you know well I
thought mission aims in Iowa State and
so let's say I do go in and I have had
some big appearances in there and you
know they've had the Rotary clubs and
the Sportsman's Club and whatever and
I've spoken to them I know those people
are in Iowa State it's a big deal when
they do a game and I got it and it I
didn't care if it was Iowa State or if
it was a Chicago Bears
the numbers are certainly different but
it's it's just as important to those fan
bases so so you owe them that when you
when you go in and the passion the
passion that we deal with in sports is
an incredible an incredible part of of
what we do and I think you have to
respect that because without those fans
that we don't have anything I mean
that's it's abated a very comfortable
living for for me through the year so I
I was in Starkville a couple weeks ago
Mississippi State and that was just as
important to me as on Tuesday night I go
an election to the last play that play
game with with Kentucky I you know I'm
welcome to small town I knew how
important those little games were to be
even went out when I was a kid up at
Montana and I love the fans I love them
dearly
well it you can tell that and I think
you have to love it if you're gonna go
into college towns and you know do it a
couple times a week but you've also been
involved in the big games you know
Georgetown Villanova you you were there
when Joe Namath made his Super Bowl
prediction poolside
I mean you you've been around a lot of
great events is there one that stands
out that
that you never talk about talking about
you know what you just mentioned it
Joe Namath at poolside before Super Bowl
3 I'd that's the only photograph that I
ever had autographed by somebody and I
was looking at the other day Sports
Illustrated came in and did a piece on
Walter Yost was the photographer you
Neal lifer and they were doing a special
on on Walter and of course that's the
photograph that I remember okay my ego
I'm in it I'm in the thing sitting
around Joe it cool site but if you look
at the rest of it you think about it
what would that photograph means first
of all you've got chill with that great
great engaging smile he's never lost it
he's near in Jupiter Florida he's so
nice the people used to play here at the
Loxahatchee Club and ride his daughters
around in a golf cart and it's you look
at that smile and there's a lady that in
fact there's two ladies in behind him
and that chaise lounge they wanted
autographs and he obliged now we're
talking we're just talking a couple days
before the Super Bowl everybody has to
understand that is a quarterback he's
everybody go to the Super Bowl and those
are writers so today you would never get
close to anybody a quarterback at that
time if you were a newspaperman in fact
you'd see cameras around him and in the
digital apparatus that now records all
those things with a change and the
growth in people forget that that was
the week that Pete Rozelle said okay
we're going to call the Super Bowl it it
had been the NFL AFL championship game
for the first couple of bowls that I had
covered it's a writer I had moved to
radio and was transitioning then and Ed
Ingalls is kind of cropped off in the
back of legendary New York radio guy
standing there with the recorder at Joe
gave him an interview you've got side
burek from Dayton with the newspaper
over his head because of the Sun and and
next to him Chuck Heaton from from
Cleveland and then you've got ray Suns
next to me on the cardigan sweater from
the from the from the sun-times he got
Jerry glean from Detroit right off to
his left that the picture means so much
to me because of of what the Super Bowl
has become and the fact that then Arlene
and I went to the country cuz of my wife
and we went
to dinner that we heard Joe guarantee it
and when I tell people listen they're
quite surprised but it was more
matter-of-fact that it was private socio
it wasn't Joe if this and I guarantee
we're gonna beat the Baltimore Colt no
he just said I guarantee it and off we
went so that's all it means a lot to me
all right well stay out of trouble and
you'll stay in touch all right can you
do that Brent I I will for you my friend
as you know that anytime Thank You Brent
that's Brent Musburger the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]